it will be very much up to the free
market or the the Veterans Health
Administration as part of the government
but it's actually very in a disruptive
ly innovative healthcare system but in
general when disruption occurs there
always are people who are profiting
handsomely from businesses the way it
has always been done and when you
attempt to disrupt them they very
frequently will then lobby the
government for protection so that they
don't they don't suffer the consequences
of disruption so when was a good example
toyota disrupted General Motors and Ford
in the 1960s Toyota did not enter the
market with Lexus's they came in at the
bottom of the market with a very cheap
simple subcompact car called a Corona
and they went then from a Corona Tudor
cell to Corolla to Camry to an Avalon to
a 4runner and then to Alexis and as they
were coming up General Motors and Ford
saw them just eating away at the lowest
profit part of the GM and Ford product
line and so GM and Ford went to the
government said you got to keep these
guys out of our country because we're
going to need to lay our people off and
so they set up import quotas to keep
Toyota at bay and almost every
disruptive innovation in some way has
has suffered that you set up regulations
to protect the incumbents and if the
government tries to create nationalize
the health care system in one way or the
other the problem is that in a democracy
the people who have the most at stake
are the incumbents not the disruptors
and the way they influence how voting
occurs
honestly and dishonestly creates
tremendous barriers and inabilities to
change a national system